in my house I hope he's wrong about that
we're gonna begin with this though
alarming new numbers on the scale of
human suffering caused by the corona
virus as America sees long lines of
people waiting to be tested there were
more than 71 thousand new cases of the
disease confirmed just yesterday nearly
1,200 more people died and that's
according to Johns Hopkins Anthony we're
also seeing a new spike in the number of
people so sick with the disease they
can't get well at home nearly 60,000
Americans are currently hospitalized due
to the corona virus that's close to a
record dr. Anthony Fauci now warns the
virus may never fully go away Jamie
yuccas reports from Santa Monica
California one of many areas struggling
through a surge in California the virus
shows no signs of slowing down
this state set a single-day record more
than six months into the pandemic and
now has the most cases in the country
health officials say kovat 19 is now on
track to be the second leading cause of
death in Los Angeles County nearly 60
percent of the cases we're now seeing
are among our young adults
as cases rise across the country dr.
Anthony foul she says coronavirus may
never fully disappear I think we
ultimately will get control of it I
don't really see us eradicating it Ohio
Indiana Minnesota and the District of
Columbia have now joined the list of 33
states with some form of mandatory mask
requirements where a mask
socially distance and repeatedly wash
your hands President Trump again touted
the importance of wearing a mask
Wednesday he also says it's safe for
kids to return to the classroom
including his own son and grandchildren
comfortable with that I just read having
to do with children and and safety and
they're very impressive they're very
strong immune systems most of California
will not return to on-site learning this
fall and is now adding new guidelines in
35 high-risk counties including places
like Hair Salons this is the only way
they can operate is outdoors we're
literally being kicked to the curb and
saying if you want to maintain your
livelihood go out on the streets
stylists say the added expense on top of
new rules have made it nearly impossible
for their businesses to survive to you
know provide for our families salon
owners point to a recent study by the
CDC that concludes indoor operations
with proper protocols are safe already